E aqui estamos mais uma vez com mais um
pode né que eu vou para eu explicar
sempre convidado que a gente faz de
conta que a galera não leu o título e
não viu a foto não sabe quem é né então
deixa a câmera só em mim explicar por
convidado que é que chama mais um pode
que na minha opinião se chama mais um
podcast é só mais um a gente quer que
seja totalmente diferente mas é um
convidado né uma pessoa os dois
bate-papo não é uma entrevista então
acaba que vira mais um pode então nesse
Episódio aqui de mais um pode o meu
convidado é o tetracampeão mundial é
exatamente nosso brasileiro tem quatro
sinto romance tem quatro títulos
mundiais está aqui na minha frente hoje
é o pó né Obrigado pelo convite ou aqui
com vocês sabe que para mim ver um
negócio muito doido tipo agora eu tô
sentado com um pó na frente eu não tô
tipo na plateia de um outro programa E
aí eu vi o Popó e eu encontrei com ele
lá tipo eu chamei o pow pow pow pow veio
mas não é muito
eu não sabia porque o seguinte a
primeira vez que eu te vi foi para um
show seu né Eu tava na plateia
assistindo com você Depois a gente fez
uma amizade no no camarim e tudo aí
depois a gente veio com essa coisa de
luta aquela coisa do box aqui negócio
todo e foi tudo natural não foi nada
programado aquela coisa toda Então eu
fico muito feliz do convite né Eu sei
que não é qualquer um que você traz aqui
para o seu habitat Até porque eu acho
que você trouxe para lutar para se
estudar um pouco das minhas técnicas dá
uma olhada Toda trabalhada no olho para
ver se eu vou aguarela Ele quer saber do
pé vamos lutar ou não vamos lutar rapaz
Vamos trocar umas porrada não lutar nós
vamos lá vamos incentivar e motivar o
box eu acho que essa galera do esporte
precisa realmente e mudei esse conceito
as pessoas Acho que só quem luta é que
luta acabou é o lutador é o cara que
troca a sopa o cara sair não eu vou te
falar que aconteceu comigo quando eu
subir nos palcos assim tipo eu era um
aspirante a humorista né eu queria eu
queria a dica das pessoas aquilo pessoal
me ensinasse me dissesse como era mas o
pessoal dizia que eu tá
é errado o que eu tava fazendo eu subia
lá quer falar mais isso aí não é comédia
comédia é isso é para levar o cara tudo
bem que eu não sei não sou entendido que
nem você mas eu tô afim de fazer o povo
rir igual você tá então tipo assim o
mesmo sentido é o está até qualquer hora
e a luta até porque você não é do Ceará
né porque os Cullen e humorista da onde
do Ceará eu acho que nunca nunca surgiu
amores nunca vi falar que tinha
humorista de nome a nível nacional e
internacional com você do Piauí nunca
mensagem para prima galera que eu sou
porque eu sou muito fã do Piauí assim
que é o pessoal que que é aquele pessoal
que você é que nem você deve ter os seus
Ídolos que você está se baseando não
sabe nem que está se baseando por ele
quem sabe né que era o João Cláudio
Moreno o Dirceu Andrade alguns amigos
meus assim o meu irmão excloud Isso
entendi não tem uma exceção que eu mais
um grande luta e você sabe da do tamanho
do cara tá ligado mesmo tipo não é o não
é o que o a galera tá dizendo total
a contar para o cara Dizendo ele é o
melhor treinador né o talento ele tem a
estrela aqui no Abreu e você era o cara
que tem o talento EA estrela brilhou
para você e você saiu então tá vendo a
que brilhou para nós mas graças a Deus
que é porque o cara que dorme no chão de
uma casa desse tamanho aqui até os 23
anos que não tinha nem janela na minha
casa tão pequena que era então a estrela
bebeu mesmo não sei lá uma parada de
perspectiva que eu falo muito pra galera
também porque a pessoa as pessoas às
vezes pedindo para mim De onde você tem
que tanta ideia no caso seria o que a
galera pergunta para ti tipo de onde tu
tirou tanta vontade porque quando a
gente está num lugar onde ele não tem
nada tipo eu também já dormir no lugar
de 100 móvel só com um cachorro E aí as
vezes eu mesmo ficar me perguntando o
que diabo é que eu tô fazendo aqui atrás
de um negócio que me deito no chão que
eu faço isso que lá em casa minha mãe
fala assim vem para cá meu filho aqui
tem comida que tem isso aqui tem aquilo
e você fica não mãe tá tudo certo aqui
tá tranquilo mas é aí que vem esse
ideias Se a gente não tivesse passado o
que seria
o presente o que seria do nosso futuro
não teria nada porque fosse a gente teve
um passado difícil com dificuldade com
aprendizado com um chute com soco com
desprezo com ignorância a gente teve
esse passado atrás o que é que a gente
pega ele hoje eu pego isso hoje joguei
tudo em cima de mim eu não precisei
bater não precisei agredir ninguém na
rua roubar roubar você fazer nada o que
eu peguei de tudo isso por ter um pai
alcoólatra que batia muito na minha mãe
é eu tinha uma vizinhança que era movida
a a muitas drogas que era movido a
confusão e briga todo tempo peguei tudo
isso Whindersson e coloquei isso como
objetivo de vida como objetivo de vida
eu não sei e não estar naquele bairro
aonde muita gente sofreu eu frequento o
bairro onde eu fui nascida e criada mas
eu mudei de latam eu consegui sair de lá
mas não consegui tirar ele dentro de mim
isso Tem a certeza absoluta
Bom dia amor o meu bike eu estou todo
dia lá treinando na academia do meu
irmão mas eu não queria passar e ser a
minha vida toda o que é aquele bairro
proporcionar Você concorda também que
tipo se não fosse o esporte que talvez
você tivesse entrado nesse nessa mesma
também também porque eu com 12 e 13 anos
Comecei a treinar Box eu vi meus amigos
nas drogas eu achava aquilo cara uma
coisa de outro mundo e todo tempo uma
chama ação né todo tempo onda com a
gente todo tempo vamos ali ele não tempo
entre é sempre assim hoje em dia eu falo
muito essa galera mais jovem tudo para
de um bora ali para de vamos aqui para
de uma festinha aquela coisa toda vai
assistir concentra naquilo que você quer
que mudou minha vida com você não pode
ser diferente você pode ser melhor do
que eu até naquilo que você faz ou
crescer mais do que eu ou possa ser
igual possa ser que até que você
aprendeu Box mas não se desenvolveram em
cima do ringue você desenvolveu ele
nenhum aluno em um como técnico entendeu
como treinador de boxe Eu falo sempre as
pessoas como olheiro se não tem se não
tem o dom
o computador o talento sentado vai ser
treinador para ganhar seu dinheiro cara
eu conheço muita gente que faz isso que
hoje vive disso surgiu pó na década de
90 o box tá lá embaixo último campeão
que a gente tinha foi o Éder Jofre em 77
depois de quase 25 anos o Brasil sem um
campeão mundial eu vou lá e quebra esse
tabu E aí todo mundo começou a fazer box
ou é ser campeão mundial é ruim disso é
o seguinte as academias antigamente de
Classe A e B não existia Box porque Box
era marginalizado o boxe as pessoas e
aprender o box na Bahia para brigar
atrás do trio na rua aí daqui a pouco
surgiu pode uma família pobre que tinha
isso é que tinha era sempre foi assim na
Bahia sempre o pessoal trava box para
brigar na hora na hora da raiva na hora
da pipoca entendeu e eu tirei isso tudo
na cabeça das pessoas que ser lutador de
boxe é ser diferente é você tem uma
linguagem diferente nada a verdade
brigam nada nada nada a ver com brigador
de trigo eu mostrava em cima do ringue
que aquela pessoa que estava em
é totalmente diferente do que estava que
aquela pessoa que tava falando 21
potencial totalmente diferente em cima
do ringue e tá na usando uma parada para
totalmente diferente ao Mediterrâneo
muitos aquele que brigaram na rua que
nós vai pegar na rua quando botava luva
acabou um homem não existia mais homem
não existe aquele valentão que ele cara
que derrubava todo mundo acabou porque a
técnica a disciplina o aprender do box
Caraípe surgiu o título mundial porque
era o título mundial estava tão
confiante de ser campeão mundial que eu
comprei uma casa fiado para minha mãe de
um mês antes da da luta eu compro uma
casa fiada por lá perguntando para
mulheres tinham essa casa aqui que era
até tia do meu do meu Tradutor só eu
quero comprar essa casa eu não quero
voltar com o título mundial e dormir
naquela casinha no chão de novo Me vende
essa casa quando eu voltar eu pago eu
vou pagar eu trouxe certeza é quase
certeza você tem que eu vou arrancar a
cabeça dele é oportunidades que eu tenho
eu quero mudar minha vida amor da vida
da minha família vai ver como eu vou
tanto a cara dele lá realmente literal
o meu cara de balão de oxigênio ele saiu
do reino de balão de oxigénio Russo
anatoly alexandrov se E aí galera
ventilando mente lado ele e no outro dia
ele acordou mas foi mas não foi a raiva
do lutador raiva do cara foi a conquista
do título mundial e pagar uma casa fiado
cara Nada não é que eu fiz uma pergunta
é tudo viu véio volta que pagar de
qualquer jeito entendeu então foi isso
cara e ainda foi a primeira vez que eu
for sensação de ser de chegar lá a
primeira vez você teve está lá com Mudou
alguma coisa porque as pessoas também
pergunta para mim se para mim ouvir
algum divisor de águas em que eu virei
alguma outra coisa diferente é o que na
cabeça de um start porque quando uma
pessoa chega a ser campeão mundial ou
que tinha alguém vai que a pessoa para
pessoa deve pensar assim o que tinha e
até aqui eu vou bem mais longe antes eu
não tinha tanta coisa diferente naquele
naquele naquela na França em cana Esse é
o meu tipo de UTI mundial foi primeira
vai viajar para fora também não não já
tinha ver
a planejar negociações já bati americano
lá já era pobre assim já era mas é tipo
assim o fodão do Jaraguá e vai ficar
aqui e você todo o estado já conhecia
porque eu já derrubei americano entendeu
É tipo top 10 e cheguei e sorriso e
quando eu escutei o texto mundial já era
o 2º do ranking mundial entendeu Então
pessoal já sabia que era uma corte a dor
quando foi disputar o título mundial já
tinha 24:24 nocaute então não vou olha
aí ela fez assim essa é tipo de cinturão
ou é nocauteou é porrada demais aqui
quando eu cheguei na França a primeira
coisa que eu vi foi um outdoor com a
foto do cara e meu nome é pequeno
embaixo entendeu Já vi que tinha algo
diferente um pouco na festa na festa a
festa lá para o cara mas entrevista tudo
pessoal falou ele ele falou na
entrevista que é a única pessoa famosa
que ele conheceu no Brasil era
Ronaldinho fenômeno entendeu era futebol
que ele conhecia Box Eu não conhecia que
ele vai pegar o carro do cara vai voltar
com o número dois é não sabe o número
dois não eu adversário que não estuda
seu oponente por aí Só que infelizmente
ele
o e procurou onda com cara totalmente
diferente não quero esperar lá ele tava
devendo a casa da vida toda toda minha
família seu filho Caçula de cinco homens
na minha casa entendeu então
e foi difícil até uma parada que é você
dar uma guinada de de tipo acontece isso
motivo os meus irmãos também eu vim meu
meu irmão é formado em medicina e eu via
o cara se formando sabia que o cara
tinha que a cabeça medicina veterinária
né Eu vi o cara o cara aí não atrás da
parada dele eu falei assim por a minha a
minha parada não é que nem a dele eu
sabia que eu minha caminhada era um
pouco diferente assim É eu sabia que
para eu poder quebrar esse essa esse
mesmo caminho porque o pai quer um se
formar a mãe quer um filho formado a mãe
quer a segurança ela pensa assim se Deus
o livre o dia eu tô aqui meu filho tem
uma formação aí garantir uma parada para
ele o negócio e eu olhava assim para o
meu irmão eu estudando e voltando com os
livros fazem que ele curte ele gostava
ele era interessado ele gosta de animal
então era uma parada assim mesmo na
minha casa é diferente eu era eu era eu
era ninguém porque eu era um Caçula de
cinco homens e os dois mais velhos É
eu tinha um que morava na casa da
madrinha então a gente não tinha
expectativa de nada eu estudei até a 4ª
série do primário na época e aí pronto
aí O o que é que eu vou fazer vou vou
ter que concentrar tudo em mim eu parei
de estudar né com 13 anos e não eu quero
tabox eu quero ser campeão de Boxe
realmente é box para tu então ou então
eu tô aguentando mais não ganhava
dinheiro eu sonhava em ganhar dinheiro
com Box eu treinava meu autógrafo com 13
anos eu escrevi a popó campeão mundial
Então eu tinha né foco e eu via também
na academia que eu era um cara
diferenciado eu consegui abater em caras
maiores do que eu homens eu comprei 100
anos eu não tava com homens naquela
época não que não 16 anos e eu fiz ali
na tora para o nosso Nordeste por um
cara que tinha vindo da ordem das
Olimpíadas seu 88 para aquele 90 é uma
cara com 30 e poucos anos já Wilson eu
for lá e bate no cara entendeu E aí eu
mostrava para mim mesmo que eu era
diferenciado por tem algo diferente eu
vou aproveitar isso eu fazer o quê
e vamos entrar no box só quero ser
lutador de box aí foi para três
Brasileiro 2000 roubaram chegava aqui em
São Paulo Paulo nos Paulista deve 3 a 2
segundo Brasil que eu fui pau pau dela
três a dois no terceiro que eu fui local
ser todo mundo mas quando cheguei no
primeiro áudio segunda série aí ninguém
mais me roubou aí fui para eliminatórias
Seleção Brasileira foi para a Seleção
Brasileira foi Panamericano em 95 foi
medalhista de prata nos jogos
pan-americanos 95/95 para ser
profissional minha primeira luta contra
o paulista Adriano Soares ganha por
nocaute com 34 segundo o primeiro um
cabo só Paulo foi 29 lutas 29 nocautes
consecutivos batendo recorde my tais
como nocautes consecutivos se prepare
para se prepara que o bicho vai pegar ai
vou fazer igual o tetracampeão você
imagina o que é você ser campeão eu uma
vez eu falava assim
a assistir às Olimpíadas aí eu vi as
pessoas primeiro né o primeiro segundo e
terceiro aí eu sério vou ficar assim
triste né você meio para baixo aí olhava
para ele pensar assim mais rápido ele é
o sete o mundo todo é muita gente
moleque é o sete eu sei falar assim a
bota todo mundo para nadar hoje aí nada
todo mundo povo desgraçado vai chegar em
sétimo entendeu é um bocado eu faço
empurra eu sou feliz ao seu sétimo
entendeu Eu sou feliz não sei ao certo
de box no mundo todo tem um mundo todo
uma Box
em todos os países do mundo todo têm
grandes lutadores é possível notar que é
por isso que eu não acho que o Brasil é
um lugar que é dizem interessado no box
eu acho que tipo Box o Brasil só não tem
televisão acho que a dor de boxe em cada
esquina e daí não tá entendendo tipo
assim porque é o esporte tão amado é tão
bonito é gostoso de fazer tá ligada
porque até uma coisa que quero falar
para o espectador normal se vê o normal
que vai no fórum não é uma pessoa normal
que que pega o documento tem que ir no
cartório e fazer uma negócio das pessoas
às vezes pergunta para mim se Mas você
vai botar no pau mesmo mas se for vai te
matar Aí eu falava assim amigo ele não
vai me matar porque o box não é para
matar ninguém aí mano tá ligado ele não
quer chegar lá e me esbagaçar porque não
é esse sentido Não é esse o intuito
Quando vamos dizer quando dois lutadores
profissionais de box né dois lutadores
assim dedicado que amam o boxe então
aqui eu não quero matar o outro ele quer
um ganhar por ele quer a
eu disse da Além disso dá um show porque
ele sabe que o espectador quer ver um
bom Box é a promoção unbox muito bonito
entendeu ele ele acha bonito lá e cá tá
ligado ele até achar legal um cara que
chega e arregaça no primeiro round e de
todo o cara ele até a chamada PEC é um
cara seu gol no futebol é mas aí tipo se
ele fizer isso quatro cinco minutos ser
luta que ela vai falar assim o rapaz eu
queria ver o cara ele treinar tanto eu
queria ver ele fazer aquele negócio que
ele faz naquela hora entendeu então tipo
eu sei falar para você acha que o povo
vai chegar e vai querer acabar com o
show acabar com a festa e dizer assim eu
sou todo mundo sabe que ele é muito bom
todo mundo sabe que ele é o campeão tem
como porque as pessoas querem ver quem é
o Whindersson Nunes primeiro isso e eu
na verdade como lutador profissional eu
tenho que mostrar para o público quem é
você eu não posso chegar em eu luto para
quem é uma porta eu só não vamos a peça
é ninguém sabe quem é você do box eu
falo com as pessoas Rapaz eu tenho que
tomar muito cuidado
e não porque ele possa ser que seja
perigoso para mim não é isso não é o
perigo é o seguinte porque eu como
lutador profissional eu sei controlar
minha mão e eu sei o peso da minha mãe
isso eu sei como colocar a minha mão e
você não tem essa experiência a maior
verdade você não tem essa experiência aí
como você o peso da sua mão manda aqui
pesa a sua mão é o copo que vai doer eu
sei que você vai jogar uns pombo sem Asa
com a gente fala eu estou preparado para
tudo para saber peso para defender que
ir para esquivar aquela coisa porque eu
quero que as pessoas saibam o armamento
que você tem o que que você tem de arma
que conheçam de vem trazer de bagagem é
deu o quê que o cara que foi só uma luta
Pô cara fez uma luta como amador o
hipopótamo sou 38 [ __ ] o cara nunca fez
uma luta contra o sol para portas 43
para o cara nunca foi nem campeão
piauiense de boxe Popó já foi três vezes
campeão baiano aí é brasileiro
brasileiro e sul-americano entre América
e mostra americano em Madagascar a porta
então o que que a gente quer
a gente quer que esse cara seja um cara
diferenciado porque o humorista todo
mundo sabe já é igual a minha o pessoal
na rua perguntei para o corpo acabou boa
que você faz o quê agora eu tenho amigo
não você não interessa você o que é que
eu entendeu mas eu não sou lutador burro
porque todas as vezes que eu lutei eu
guardava 60 e gostava 40 então só para
você ter ideia eu não sou burro eu tô de
boa entendeu Eu tô bem Eu graças a Deus
hoje eu consigo manter meu patamar de
vida que muita gente acha que você é
humorista tá bom que você não faz nada
isso aqui é se isto tem que ser preparou
ninguém acha que foi ideia sua ninguém
presta aqui eu passo aí daqui um dia de
madrugada eu falei assim ser rápido
senão se eu fizesse ninguém pensa né e
tipo eu tô nunca perdeu um profissional
não perdi duas lutas profissional a
minha primeira derrota foi dia sete de
agosto de 2004 Olha só olha olha olha
como Olha a pele como Deus preparou essa
derrota para mim eu perdi eu peguei meu
título sete de agosto de 99
o e perdi meu título Sete de Agosto de
2004 foram cinco anos defendendo o
motivo cinco anos é Battery gente Foram
dez defesas de cinturão Mundial mais um
cinturão de super campeão mundial por
ter defendido da Lei no cinturão né E aí
bota o mesmo árbitro que foi ato da
minha luta contra o Russo uma coleção
nova para ser o mesmo ato da luta contra
Diego corais ou que coincidência então
foi tudo preparado abrem certinho foi
Acho que sem o cara foi melhor do que eu
o Diego coragem naquela noite foi melhor
do que eu e ele aproveitou a
oportunidade e eu fui nocauteado por
nocaute técnico no décimo áudio mas até
o oitavo round eu tava ganhando como é
que é tomar um nocaute Eu não apaguei
não foi feito fui acender o dia eu apago
é legal doente né então levantei aí cair
de novo aí levantei contou Aí voltei
cair de novo e eu vou falar para vocês
uma coisa muito interessante poucas
pessoas sabem você também não sabe o que
aconteceu naquela roupa é Deus com muito
bom comigo naquela Lu
é a minha segunda queda eu senti muito o
soco dele na minha segunda Ketlin eu aí
quando o hábito controle levantei aquela
coisa toda eu ia para cima dele rapaz
teve uma coisa que está Luciano não vá
parou eu aí parei eu falei que não
queria mais e eu passei cinco dias
seguida assim com muita dor de cabeça
que eu nunca senti na minha vida só de
um lado e eu fiz vários exames aquela
coisa toda com melhores neuro Salvador
aquilo tudo e ninguém sabia o que era aí
eu peguei um neuro lá em Salvador bom
para caramba e pedir para ele me
acompanhar e paguei paguei para ele e
particular ele só vai acompanhar nesse
exame e aí tinha uma vez assim a partida
na minha cabeça ele falou que é normal
às vezes as pessoas um acidente de carro
até em uma queda pode acontecer isso a
gente vai medicamento vai para saber sua
cabeça podia fazer nada tudo mas foi até
bom você ter parado a luta porque você
pudesse tomar mais poucos pagamento
poderia ser pior o lenço pode poder voar
malhar mogno né
e Graças a Deus não precisa abrir você
aprender nada tomar remédio coagro a
Viradinha restaurou tá aquilo tudo e
depois eu vou ter lutar aí graças a Deus
mas acho que foi Deus mesmo na creche
que é porque tipo a pessoa normal ela
não tem noção do que que é eu eu tenho
noção que poucas pessoas sabe disso
nunca falei assim tempo de mídia no
entrevista um bico né nunca falou né E
me tratei passei cinco dias internado em
tratamento de graça dela toda deu tudo
certo nessa dela está em mais um título
mundial tá vendo cara tá vendo aí foi
bom ter parado nem você falou que Deus
preparou até a hora de hoje dois anos
depois que eu tinha esse mesmo que eu
perdi desafio coragem de novo os a Fiat
já fez a feira abandonou o título não tô
comigo os seus ficou vago aí eu lutei
contra a americano chamado sarin sarin
relevo no dia vinte acho que foi 29 de
Abril de 2006 aí levei meu time no
último título mundial Nossa eu falo
assim mas você sabe como que é um local
porque a pessoa normal ela ela não sabe
como que é um
e o poder de ação do lutador porque eu
tenho noção assim treinando na academia
de MMA eu tenho noção que uma pessoa um
civil normal que pegar um atleta
profissional ele tá muito enrolado se
ele vai ser muito da da assimilação que
você já tenha e do seu preparo físico
também você tiver um condicionamento
físico muito bom e você já tem uma
preparação boa de uma noção do que é
tipo assim eu já tomei Notre Dame que
não é o nocaute aquele que você cai
levanta e eu tenho experiência de cuspir
o protetor 1 e dá tempo de um hábito lá
lavar pediu que tem nada para lavar que
o tudo você aquele caiu no chão não pode
botar na boca direto aqui Dá uma
chegadinha o hábito mesmo até daqui você
não pode me pegar porque ela o seguinte
a luva de box para quem não sabe o dedo
dela é aqui né só que ela tem um negócio
que prende o dedo dela ele não abre
então você não consegue nem pegar o
protetor falar porque o dedo não abre
porque você possa ser que você deu um
golpe no cara eu e o dedo venha pegar no
olho depois que o dedo da luva de boxe
lá e fechar amarradinho né amarradinha
Pode reparar depois que tem
e tem uma cola a emenda sem venda
entendeu então aí eu tinha essa isso que
esses macetes Nós duas somos duas quedas
que eu também não te dava também encosto
protetor foi lá lavou meu trabalho lá
porque o nokdal é essa apagadinho
blackout que você dá tipo coisa coisa de
10 segundinho que você ficar um
pouquinho mais recupera você menos
porque a contagem até oito né então você
tentar bem preparado e você tentar com o
equilíbrio mental um além do normal
porque é o seguinte lado que você caiu
alto aí conta um dois três quatro cinco
seis aí você tem experiência e levantar
uns seis sete oito OK aí você volta para
luta e aí com a experiência que você tem
o que você faz você dar uma caminhada o
cara vem de vez para quem te dar o passo
dar um print na hum jogou protetor no
chão você dá uma dá uma olhada nele eu
deixei na sair você tem uma lista
entendeu E o nocaute a seguinte o o
black Black Out né
o que você tá em casa assistindo
televisão e aí falta luz povo negócio
porque você tava com uma cara na
televisão atrás de qualidade voltou a
luz voltou na hora é assim mesmo é assim
mesmo que tá assistindo um filme aí você
apagou é quando Jornal da Globo é assim
mesmo tá passando no jornal da globo não
tem um monte de você só vai recuperar só
vai saber o que é que tá passando no dia
seguinte eu vacilar Mais você tá bem
preparado aquilo tudo e o golpe não foi
tão contundente para você apagar mesmo
que tá acende mas é tipo classificado
como um que quando você um disse que
você toma que você vai acordar no dia
seguinte como se fosse uma barra não
ficar batida de carro no material dente
pouco força pagou dormiu ele ficou um
pouquinho ao meio fica um pouco com
Russo que eu botei o cara ainda teve que
que trancou né a respiração dele teve
que dar uma bombadinha para ele abrir ó
tá se focar botou a chapa do vamos lá
para resolver mas eu tinha
e eu tinha curiosidade também de saber
sabe o que tipo como você é uma estrela
que é tetracampeão mundial no caso então
tipo você tem muito só redor do mundo
inteiro não é tipo só no Brasil em você
tem funk sei lá o cara que é muito teu
fã lá da Nigéria ter ideia eu tenho uma
chave de Miami o prefeito já me deu a
chave de manhã não tá ligado eu também
até a chave de que Mary Kay netcut mas
tem muita luta de boxe só no cassino
funcionado Focus onan e já ativar as
premiações também fora do Brasil o ano
retrasado foi receber uma premiação em
Tokyo também do outro lado do mundo ele
também é impressionante que quando eu
cheguei em Tokyo eu tinha gente com foto
japonês lá que foto com cinturão réplica
de cinturão que eu assinasse então essas
conheço essas pessoas assim que eu acho
interessante porque eu não tenho eu não
tenho fãs brasileiros sim não é
brasileiro brasileiro tá sempre todo
lugar ladeiro ama brasileira Então pensa
ser amor e tudo mais mas tipo assim aí
você chegou lá e tem um japonês
galerinha ou até mesmo
o louco nunca vi tanta foto minha ela
levar para assinarem tudo em mim começou
a me seguir no Instagram em tudo que eu
posso tava lá galera tira foto tipo
assim navegando até aí queria que tu
desse um motor da autógrafo lupa até
cinturão você vê que chineses eles têm
réplica de tudo né levado réplica do
cinturão Mundial igualzinho o meu e o aí
fui lá e assim mesmo cinturão ou senão
ele tá olhando na bolsa hoje foi tirar
da boca que é isso cara igualzinho
igualzinho cara empresta a galera tipo
eu ia vem te visitar eu tipo toco viu
mais essa galera quando tu foi algum
evento convidado é uma parada em alguns
exemplos de voz também às vezes na rua
em nos Estados Unidos mesmo a galera
quer que tu vai dar uma Master classes
foram Centenário usando seminário em
todo o Brasil do seminário né E algumas
pessoas é muito bom fora do Brasil
também só com essa pandemia para cá
depois que eu parei ainda não tem como
dar não mas sim até para abrir academia
fora do país também eu tenho tem um
projeto de abrir um caderno amanhã me
tão
bom grado irado irado esse evento vai
ser um evento que vai ser muito irado
vai ser muito legal porque eu tô me
dedicando eu tô me dedicando tô vendo aí
pede treinando o WhatsApp direito você
sabe que eu tô estudando todo o seu é eu
vejo entendeu disse tudo que você possa
eu tô ligado ela vez que não vai ter
você ver não eu tô vendo assim ó é o
gancho que ele tá dando tá vendo aqui ó
ele tá abrindo um abraço muito para dar
o gancho quando ele dar o gancho direito
o braço de graça e vai na Feira da
palavra da Baixa é eu assisti o trabalho
aí eu vou lá e eu vou dar o cruzadinho
por cima então é que tem que ficar
Espera aí aí quando eu precisar de um
por cima e no instante ele vai lembrar
dessa mãozinha dele é fazer o trabalho
vai fazer sim mas o automático aqui é
lutador de boxe automática você é
calculado a mão já tem que tá aqui é o
tomate crescendo junto de seu pai daqui
tem que ser todo tempo alavanquinha
levar quando você faz hora é porque a
guarda alta é assim cara como um divisor
de águas para você porque você às vezes
é tão um golpe duro Você pode até sentir
mais a sua mão proteger um pouco eu não
nunca gostei de parar
não tá aqui não tá nem assimilando o que
é que está sendo falado aqui é como se
Entenda como se fosse um xadrez eu acho
que é por isso que é tão gostosinho de
fazer entendeu É porque não é que não é
que você é obrigado a ser o melhor toda
vez que que você é luta é que cada vez
que você luta você vai entender que tem
umas pecinhas que você vai ajustando e
que seu jogo vai ficando cada vez mais
fechadinha é fechado Mas fechar não vai
fechar você vai ver se é intocável
entendeu Aí esse negócio você tá falando
eu também vejo que eu assisti os meus
vídeos eu tô lá e quando eu executei
pareceu que para mim Foi quanto o dente
parece com meu braço entrou que minha
mão realmente foi que encaixou mas no
vídeo eu vejo que encaixou na minha mão
tava baixo é um momento que eu posso
dormir agora tem uma coisa para você e
você que é muito favorável para mim se
você não começar a mudar você vai vai
favorecer tudo para mim
E por que você não movimenta muito
devagar né parada então quanto mais o
luto com um cara parado é melhor para
você tá batendo os aqui bancada aqui eu
vou movimentar mais e vou saber onde é
que vou parar Então quando você começar
a treinar em cima do ringue a movimentar
na ponta dos pés para lá e para cá bater
porque a sua movimentação já uma defesa
porque quando você tá movimentar
movimentando Eu quero procurar você só
deu um passo para trás e a saiu do lado
e as não é difícil né muito de todos os
tempos e tentar encontrar nem voltou eu
só tenho assim eu só tenho movimentando
toda vez que o movimento que eu tô
fazendo spag que eu tô movimentando
movimentando que eu sinto que no
adversário preparou um golpe eu dou um
passo sozinho só para trás do outro lado
eu já quebrei é hum padeiro porque já
uma defesa a sua movimentação treinando
João defesa Esse é o único toque que eu
vou te dar vai ser difícil mas vai ser
legal qual que é a intenção que a gente
tava eu falei eu cheguei para o popó
quando eu fui falar com ele logicamente
eu não sei por Carlos rebolo tá
Boa tarde assim fica aberto tá ficando
doido vai dizer assim qual foi vai a
pegadinha do momento aí eu cheguei para
ele expliquei falei rapaz eu acho o box
legal não acho o boxe uma coisa
apaixonante assim toda vez que alguém
que me fala assim Ah então pega a
manopla e me ensina a fazer isso é o
ensinar diabo direto e um negocinho aqui
eu já abri eu já vejo que a pessoa tá
sem polgando eu já já aí eu já fico tá
vendo esse bichinho que acabou de
explicar o que eu volto Sem problema é
bom mesmo que me ficou Há dois anos e
meio atrás entendeu eu comecei a fazer e
eu achei tipo sensacional E aí como a
gente tava falando do início é inegável
que o esporte tira você de um lugar ruim
aí negado com o esporte ali dia você
está fazendo uma parada errado ou está
se unindo com a galera errada porque
exige um foco Exige uma dedicação EA
disciplina né E aí imagina aqui para eu
usar o meu alcance né e aliar uma força
que é tipo um campeão mundial
o Xbox erro Box veio a mãe da são ele
tira a pessoa de uma bola até porque
você quando para o box você tá minha
bola que você não conseguia sair de
dentro dela e através do esporte Você
viu que você tem outros homens você viu
que você pode botar a sua raiva toda em
um saco na mão do treinador ou um sparg
mesmo quebrando o dente aquela coisa
toda mas você faça um pouco quebrei o
dente mas foi algo prazeroso e foi
valendo então eu não fui em justo não
foi algo prazeroso algo que eu dentro do
valor entendeu E você pegar o esporte e
colocar ele como meio não como meio de
vida mas como meio de disciplina seco
meio de inclusão social porque o que a
gente vai fazer a sua inclusão social é
isso que a gente vai ajudar muitas mais
que você vai estar me incluindo o seu
círculo e eu vou estar te incluindo no
meu círculo né é o que é mais a maior
vontade de fazer o evento além também de
ganhar eu só queria eu só queria ter 10
porcento
há dez você é dez porcento Você lembra
na primeira conversa que a gente teve
meu quando eu fui falar da ideia eu
falei assim rapaz eu não admito mas que
trás tá lá tá aí tá do mesmo está
trabalhando mas que tá esse é o cara que
tá lá fazendo 14 anos sempre se
reinventando e fazendo as paredes e tudo
bem mas o cara tem quase 15 milhões de
seguidores tá ligado aí o popó tem
quatro vezes uma parada que é muito
difícil de ganhar uma vez que tem gente
que lutou a vida inteira por um e não
conseguiu um cara tem quatro e eu não me
culpo por ter poucos e não me culpa se
um cenário Nacional É porque no áudio da
minha carreira só assistir MSN Orkut né
E hoje nessas vezes nessas redes sociais
em massa né E pelo fato do conteúdo que
eu tenho conteúdo que eu tenho o box Sim
eu gosto de mostrar você vem todo dia eu
posso treinando aquela coisa toda e a
galera gosta galera curte é os pouco a
gente chega lá e tudo mais tenho certeza
que eu com
Se você pegar o pecinha vai pouquinho aí
eu chego lá onde eu quero que vai dar
certo aí você é legal vai ser bacana
achei legal para mim vai ser legal para
você vai ser legal Nordeste também que a
gente vai ter uma moral uma moral top aí
de assim a Bahia tem uma fama de
Boxeador né agora em Bahia tem uma fama
muito tem a sua forma de estado que a
baía nomeada como Cuba do Brasil né e
culpa é um lugar tem muito roteador
roteador muito muito muito cada esquina
tem computador você ter ideia em Cuba
Box a matéria de escola
o vale. Vai continua ligada Então se
prepare se essa luta foi na Bahia e você
ganha para mim sair de lá corrido não
não posso não eu já viu as todo todo
duro e Holyfield pronto pronto mais ou
menos vai sair vai ficar beirada da
cadeira da escola voando mais ou menos
isso aí então então acho que você ia em
qualquer lugar do Brasil que a gente
quiser essa luta vai ser bem-vindo
qualquer um qualquer estado é graças a
Deus eu tenho uma boa entrada em
qualquer lugar que eu vá e você também a
gente tem uma cabeça muito ruído em tudo
que aquele faz então qualquer lugar que
a gente fez essa luta vai ser vermelho e
floral Box qual é a tua fora Box assim
rapaz ama o futebol viaja o Brasil todo
quer jogar bola né eficiente a
acrescente amo jogar jogos na Seleção
Brasileira de Master System Master mais
até porque acima dos 40 anos
ex-jogadores como número viro é Mauro
Galvão é Vampeta é
o bate-bola debate bola mesmo assim
bater bola mesmo com uma seleção do seu
município ou com a câmara de vereadores
ou com Câmara de Deputados alguma coisa
ou com algum futebol massa da cidade
Marcelinho Carioca viola Júnior Baiano e
ninguém te dá nenhuma única e o único
que não é jogador de futebol nessa sou
eu entendeu ir aí é legal que todo mundo
tem uma situação muito boa em todo mundo
fica naquela velocidade de colocar o
tudo de bom jogando lado de uma galera
dessa tudo paixãozinha mas é paixãozinho
achar joga futevôlei Também Ama vai
curtir o tempo assim porque eu me liguei
que em qualquer área da vida que o cara
vai fazer tipo seja a comédia seja boxer
Sport seja aquilo quanto mais coisas
Você consome mais conhecer assistir o
intelecto vai ser melhor só que não é
rápido raciocínio você vai melhorando em
qualquer área que é que tu faz tanto
assim a entretenimento ácido assistam
agora assistir um filme eu gosto esse
filme eu não gosto de ser muito sério É
porque eu fico preso eu começo a
sentir-se 10 horas lá
o que acabo seis sete horas da manhã
porque eu não consigo falar aí eu paro
de assistir não quero mais assistir
série você vai dar certo porque caramba
aquela coisa toda igual cachaça toma um
bocado aí depois fala não quebra não é
por aí apesar que eu não bebo tudo mas
acho que o bebê se eu não queria parar
também por isso que eu nem bebo é tudo
teu é peça campeão né não porque minha
vida toda comecei cedo né Eu comecei
cedo ouvi meu pai bebendo muito não é
uma boa referência para mim o que meu
pai fazia por causa da bebida mas eu
tenho Mãe Guerreira que minha mãe é o
seguinte fazia faxina o dia todo o que
não tinha que comer de meio dia minha
mãe conseguir de noite então via aquele
lado do guerreiro Então eu peguei o lado
masculino de meu pai voltei por Bob Sam
e' o lado de guerreira da minha mãe do
dia a dia eu mandei para o box também tá
pegando uma rasgada e tem tamanho hoje
ainda é a minha mãe que minha mãe vai
pegar não pô minha mãe minha mãe você
ter ideia de dez palavras que ela fala
onde é palavrão caramba é o desbocado
para
e eu pensei Gonçalves da casa né tomou a
segunda dose agora tá arretada tá doida
para sair aqui boa então é minha mãe da
isso não aguento tomar a segunda dose
tábua de passar irresoluto possível dois
faz não vou ficar aqui em casa nada
mesma bem aos outros então minha mãe é o
seguinte As pessoas chegam em casa ela
veio de ficar longe ela quer ficar perto
ela quer já xingar já que já não é a
minha mãe ela mora no interior na
fazenda e ela pensa que o vírus não
chega longe uma ligada para o seu face
não eu não veio ninguém aqui não mas é
só quarta-feira aqui voando só quarta
mas eu tô achando que na peça o negócio
lá todo na segundo a tua mãe Pelo amor
de Deus não tem Nossa eles não tem noção
assim mas é também é aquele mesmo aquela
mesmo sentimento que você tem o é aquele
negócio de você olhar para trás virar a
correria e ficar com vontade de correr
também porque você viu que gosta de
abraçar né somente a gente mãe
nordestina gosto de eu gosto de abraçar
não quem é essa mãe nordestina que não
gosta de abraçar e sentir abraçar eu te
dou diga que qualquer coisa que
e ama você sim que é o melhor para você
né tudo mais eu tive que mentir para
minha mãe demais quando eu sair de casa
e elastina assim né você tipo assim você
chega de outro estado para Bahia tio
Bahia pouco fulana Como é o nome daquela
rua como é que eu chego naquela lá então
bora aqui que eu te levo lá na Bahia
pelo menos assim entendeu Aí a gente
pensa esse espírito de dividir tranquilo
e tava lembro que lá lá na casa da minha
avó quando era criança eu tava lá e
passava passava a gente pedir comida
mesmo quero uma parada de morar num
lugar bem ou desandar ele passava
passava volta e meia uma vez a cada uma
semana passava alguém caminhando para
uma trouxinha aí no lá para poder que
pariu passava na minha só fazer uma
pergunta para você e tipo tinha
interromper Ei já senti um gancho no
fígado já marca para sentir o mesmo
legal toda ou só já senti já senti já
senti assim eu acho que eu nunca nunca
cai é uma vez que eu caí no chão foi
contigo porque pegou você sabe fazer
e vai entender né você tá fazendo
colocar o que você sabe fazer entendeu
no meu caso aquele que você fez aquele
que você deu eu tentaria dar tipo com
muito mais força menos técnica muito
menos colocado Não foi bem colocadinha
foi bem lugar certo ouvir o clipe
entendeu mas toda vez que eu vou fazer
espalhem né os e outra que ele gosta eu
não te dei com a mão direita minha mão
tô ruim você deu assim ele tem como
arrumar hoje queda porque a mão esquerda
porque a mão esquerda ela não pega no
braço a mão esquerda pega no fígado e o
golpe de direita pegar no braço não dói
não tem feito nenhum mas o bloco que tem
feito é aqui em cima desmanche que é da
minha filha não queira da mesma ela
desse lado ele só dá uma balançada mas
nem lembram não tem feito mesmo aqui que
dói a noite ficando assim de quem é sua
gancho gancho de esquerdo
E isso não tem toda vez que você daí ele
não dele aberto porque senão ele vem
atrás na costela vocês tem que sentir o
seu o seu cotovelo raspar na sua na sua
isso aqui é pra de mim é isso aí eu não
sabia entendeu é que quando você dá ele
aqui você abre muito ele ele pega mais
na costela mas quando você dá ele aqui
dentro que ele pega certinho aqui já foi
eu pa subir é Eu já peguei no lugar se
eu não fosse voltar com o pote e
treinávamos lado tá aqui ó é melhor não
sei que preparar ele eu faço diz pai
geralmente com a outra galera tem Às
vezes a minha defesa no segura alguns
acerto eu sinto mas não é que seguro dá
para tô com a barriga dura tá dando para
segurar mas quando a luta Mineiro que é
atualizar mas ele é e a Poxa 12 anos
profissional e tudo mais aí ele ele
consegue toda vez que quer acertar E aí
acho que ele dá que é para poder o saber
o que que
é de um golpe do fígado que é que é uma
que eu acho que dá mais precisa ficar
perguntando a roupa minha aí vai botar a
mão embaixo na esse povo só no último
rock é o certo é só noite moral disse
primeiros de sair de brincar ela ver se
ele se soltar e vai lhe matar eu digo só
ser último Hum será que as pessoas estão
falando também E aí que vai aguentar vai
ser que o preparo físico dele vai
aguentar tudo aquela coisa toda esses
velho se ele não colocar para cima
presta atenção vou te falar se você não
colocar
e é muito você coloca raiva se você
colocar ânsia se você colocar desejo de
fazer e não tá conseguindo você vai
cansar se você deixar as coisas
acontecer tudo natural Tudo que você
tenha outro pa a gente vai fazer 10 15
20 aos agora se você colocar a sua
respiração na sua cabeça vai embora
junto com que eu tô pensando né junto
com tudo o que é que aqueles que era
fazer boa iluminação e quente quero na
sua Branca porque é de cama ela vai ter
câmera ela que eu tô te esquentar muito
também [ __ ] o público o que é que o
povo vai pensar que eu não posso fazer
não não você tem que deixar tudo natural
Tudo por fluir sem ninguém tem eu e você
E outra eu vou deixar fluir entendeu eu
não vou chegar por favor pô vou acabar
com a minha festa eu acabar com a sua
festa não a gente vai fazer a festa
juntos vamos fazer uma festa juntos
entendeu a ideia é essa não vamos fazer
uma festa não eu também sei que você não
a pessoa maldosa não não quer eu lutador
maldoso é assim desejar
E é exatamente existe o lutador maldoso
existe a pessoa que quer que o negócio
aconteça que funcione é porque eu também
eu paro eu faço espalhem eu não achei
interessante que eu fico batendo não mas
não não não digo eu digo assim a
diferença o Ismael treino né mas assim
eu não acho interessante como se fosse
na proporção de um evento em que eu só
bato é legal muito boa você quando você
só bate que você vem da história que
você quer ser um lutar dois aqui aqui na
se ando vai deixa eu te falar uma coisa
muito interessante pode escolher difícil
para mim quando ela lá e cá eu acho
muito mais legal que eu acho que eu tô
jogando de fato eu tô jogando agora
quando você fizer um Spike você tenha o
cara tem a mesma qualidade técnica que
você e você tem que se soltar
Independente de quem esteja lá porque
você tá treinando para fazer uma
exibição top tá e quando você tá
transando com um cara que é muito top
você não consegue se soltar porque você
fica com esse aí do que vem de lá é
supernormal um disso então quê que eu
quero te falar que quando a gente fizer
não fique
o que vem de lá porque eu sei o que é
que eu posso eu sei as armas que eu
tenho entendeu E você quiser você acaba
com o negócio Eu e você arruma que eu
tenho você e a força da mesma Polo não
faltei os cara na casa da minha pergunta
de 18 anos se eu quiser aí para mim
valeu mas eu sempre eu já não gostei
muita gente a três semanas atrás eu
brinco com Oscar na academia mas quando
eu dou uma apertadinha eu tenho que dar
uma parada porque eu sei que eu não vou
fazer mais com aquele cara porque eu vou
machucar ele então é melhor a gente
brincar e eu vou fazer mais House que eu
aproveitar ele do que eu machucar ele
então eu sei o peso da minha exatamente
né E o que é que a gente vai fazer para
a gente vai Popó luva de luta de 8 e 10
onças de Campo será que a gente vai
fazer isso intensidade de um matar o
outro é que a gente fazer luva de 14 11
e 12 11 hora que 14 gel é essencial para
uma dor de fazer um para ficar aquele
negócio grandão na né acho que vai ficar
12 horas que eu posso ela que a gente
vai ter necessidade de lutar é 8 ou 10
de três minutos não mas não pode fumar
ktastro oito áudio de 2 minutos
a gente não pode fazer também oito de 2
ou 10 dois entendeu então a gente vai
fazer uma coisa que vai ser agradável
para mim para você e para o público e
para galera que eu eu que na verdade é
os que a nossa maior preocupação porque
a gente vai se divertir aí eu sei que a
gente vai se divertir achei nossa
preocupação maior mesmo esse a galera
vai se divertir também tanto quanto a
gente vai ser só que a galera deve
pensar e quem tá do outro lado pelo Face
amor isso é só que você não humorista
igual a Tirulipa você não humorista
humorista igual a Tiririca né que ele
para
e o modelo para tentar fazer outro moro
em cima do modelo não você já faz o
almoço eu grupo né Junior isso não é
consegue fazer isso ele pega um modelo e
consegue fazer outro monte em cima do
muro e Tirulipa vai também né e na luta
você não vai poder fazer para essas irmã
as pessoas não Saram as muita gente ah o
cara vai brincar vai fazer uma palhaçada
alguma coisa ele pode até tentar é dar
uma pancadinha no braço pode tentar
fazer um jogo uma firula firula alguma
coisa assim mas ele não vai o tempo todo
fazer isso não vai pegar 78 rádio novela
de evento ele fazendo não ele vai querer
soltar um pouco a mão vai querer fazer
como se fosse uns bairro ir na academia
e ainda a ideia é essa é a ideia a gente
fazer algo que marque né não é que marca
minha vida comutador que minha vida
computador já tá marcada mas a sua vida
como montador não tem nada marcar nada
até o cara que você pegou e agora agora
eu vou carimbar' beleza dela sabe sabe
por quê Porque não foi uma coisa assim
que
eu esperava ou no início diferente é
muito novo uma coisa muito muito nova se
você fizesse aqui você fez com cara em
um ringue uma coisa bem pai eu acho que
daria muito mais impacto do que ser
feito em uma gaiola entendeu não foi
assim mangá pouco para quem viu ele foi
uma brincadeira dentinho dela assim que
a luta de um de box Ricardo de briga né
é diferente é diferente acho que você
poderia ter aproveitado naquela
oportunidade eu só tive uma experiência
de box dentro de um ringue de boxe mesmo
assim para mim foi um dos espaços mais
legais que eu fiz na minha vida porque
as cordas são outra parada é você
encostar nas cordas quando o adversário
está vindo até você e você encosta na
outra parada tudo muito diferente é
outra ela tem cores a sua mais
visualizar e você me enxerga tá muito
mais aberto muito mais aberto você
respira mais as pessoas veem mais você é
uma coisa assim eu acho que uma luta de
boxe é um show é isso mesmo não é não é
aquela coisa eu
a minha não foi uma luta né é um alemão
para tomar de gladiador mas cadeado
aquela coisa do cara aqui né aquela e o
box não é colocar coisa mais tradicional
mais aberta que todo mundo assistir hoje
as velhas e os velhos cometeu volta Hum
e muitos falam até Poxa não gosto muito
de mim não mas o bloco só assim isso
aquela coisa toda a volta é muito bom
mas teve muita gente que disse para mim
que parou de assistir Box depois que
você parou de lutar boxe Tipo tinha
muita gente que que acompanhava o box
com o mesmo assim não acompanhava o box
que eu gostava de ver um bom Box gostar
de ver o pó fazendo box do pop aberta aí
quando deu aquela o pó deu como é que
fala o hiato dele deu agora vou ficar de
boa ou já ganhei que eu tinha para
ganhar mais você que acontece se tivesse
lutadores que tivesse pegada de Punch
como eu tinha que é uma coisa fora do
normal é tipo você vai assistir Neymar
essa semana a fim de mais jogando e
e o meu negócio é ver Neymar fazer gol
cara que nem mais sou bom no dele que
ele faz cada gotas então o seguinte o
que é que o que a galera quer ver no no
no box é um nocaute é isso mesma coisa
do futebol futebol o que ele quer ver o
que o gol se eu quero assistir o Neymar
jogando porque eu quero ver gol no box é
mesma coisa nossos lutadores atuais não
tem pegada diferenciada então não tem
tanto é que eu falo assim o ok aquele
negócio assim de [ __ ] ele vai derrubar
agora e todo mundo sabe a hora que eu
largar eu vou fazer logo né pipoca vou
pegar logo não refrigerante que vai ter
nocaute entendeu e muitos até reparo
aqui esse sentimento quando o árbitro
quando tu dava nokdal e o árbitro ia
voltando e o cara tava dando uma olhada
discipular você tinha um pouco vai
voltar agora e vai trabalhar aqui agora
quando eu tenho papo tá bom mas eu vou
ter filhos quando eu voltava mesmo dava
um bom porque eu senti que aquele cara
sentiu tipo a gente nunca botei lá em
Ana Barros Eu não eu dei um toque então
é o primeiro round aí eu pude um pau na
[ __ ] naquele cara vai esposa velho esse
cara esse cara não vai conseguir voltar
sem por cento no 12º vai voltar
diferente primeira coisa que eu fiz vou
botar um nó na cabeça de tudo quanto
batendo brotou porque a gente sabe a
gente quer profissional da área da luta
não sabe mais ou menos o que é como é
que aquele cara vem aquela coisa toda
então cada alça que você é como a poli
ou sentar e voltar eu sei mais ou menos
como é que você lá e como a polícia sabe
tipo eu quero ter que dar o tio do pneu
Sabe sim sabe o carro tá indo É por isso
vai perseguir fazer pouca já vai vai
devagar você já sabe que ele já tá se
achando que tem que fazer é bater o
primeiro primeiro house né bateu bom
primeiro você foi quando você tá lá eu
já sei mais ou menos de forma mais forte
se vai voltar eu sei de que forma seu
técnico vai te orientar mais ou menos
porque eu sei qual foi o IBOPE que eu
joguei entendeu é E aí vai no decorrer
da luta eu vou enxergando a mais ali
eu vou ver mais pobre que você tá
jogando Você também tem que ter afife
vende popótamus joga muito esse igual
daqui a pouco eu tô indo muito lá
direito porque minha mão tá baixando
muito e se você tentar mudar um
pouquinho vou para o lado esquerdo para
ver o que é que ele vai fazer Pô velho
eu tô indo pro lado esquerdo ele tá [ __ ]
também eu vou tentar lutar com ele
chamando ele para trás para ver se eu
contrário eu pego e aí você muda luta é
normal é um xadrez lamento é você ver de
que forma você está melhor se é você que
a mesmo para frente se você caminhando
para trás você quer mesmo lado esquerdo
lado direito e você vai se enquadra na
luta é isso que eu faço mas não tem isso
que eu faço nenhum trem eu procuro saber
de que forma um me enquadrar melhor como
aniversário eu não deixo ele se
encontrar é muito estratégias é porque
eu acho que talvez não tem tantos
lutadores que criam sua própria
estratégia enquanto estão lutando eu
quero confia muito no seu próprio soco
ou na força que ele botou no treino
inteiro e tal e menos nenhum é o
seguinte tem muita gente que não
consegue assinar Tomando suco
se você estão soltos É pô eu tô aqui com
você eu acho que quase todo mundo não eu
tô aqui com você Você pensou em dar um
copo
é que agora você pensou de tudo aquela
coisa então cê tem tem um pouco algum
conhecimento o poder de tirar
assimilação da entender logo carai dois
tá bom deixa eu mudar a estratégia agora
é muito parado o cara tá essa Qual é o
golpe mais importante em uma luta de
boxe em um Transit boxer uma digere se
você conseguir d-abya se você conseguir
manter a distância e quebrar também Todo
pensamento do seu adversário com Jerry
você tem outra parte interna sempre deve
sempre sempre vou te dar muito legal
o lixo só quebrar muito seu pensamento
eu vou tentar tirar uma foto com certeza
aí quebrar meu pensamento morro na minha
casa você quebra meus pensamentos da
minha lembrança pode falar para sua
esposa que eu não vou machucar você que
a vontade de sua não é me de formar Nada
não é porque muita gente água muita
gente já está pensa por faltar porque
ele tá grandão Eu acho que só 2 cm menor
que você tem um metro e setenta você é
tenho 1,70 e alguma coisa eu tenho mais
68 entendeu então é tão nessa que
encontrei você pesa 80 quilos mais eu
peço por aí eu tô precisando 70/79
entendeu só que eu quero quero tá no
ringue com 6 ou não tiver prometeu um
cheirinho pra vocês viram tem botar
comprometer um shape porque faz parte do
esporte a disciplina entendeu então eu
também não vai não importa para a gente
a gente chegar lá e aí o pó tá lá
sentado passa seis meses sentado e eu
seis meses sentado aqui ó deixa aí
Comprei errado eu vou lá e cansa para o
cansa mais eu suando mais vai olhar o
Instagram do Popó é só você querer que
eu vou querer ser o cara que eu tô
colocou nunca mama
E aí que eu vou ter que ir em bar e para
mostrar que eu vou bem é isso aí é isso
aí que e eu quero mostrar também para lá
para os cara que eu vou eu vou eu vou
fazer uma um sparring né eu vou fazer um
Spike com o tetracampeão Mundial de Boxe
porque eu quero lutar boxe aí eu chamo o
cara de box para Otávio que o cara
chamou o cara do Não é não Weslei eu
quero trocar é quase Poxa o negócio do
cara chão na ligado aí chama o cara para
lutar boxe mas mas se essas essa se
depois se por acaso pintar uma
oportunidade você lutar com ele a gente
vai fazer uma preparação eu quero lutar
com o irmão dele que é o maior maior que
ele é quantos quilômetros dá de eu acho
que ele não sei mas ele deve ter 1,88
ele deve tá com 90 pouco escura e 91/90
acho que não é vantagem para o senhor tá
com cara maior que você mais pesado é
bom sou tá com cara de 70 a 80 kg que é
mais ou menos a estrutura aquilo tudo
entendeu
É muita gente que entenda você tem muita
mas não tem muito que as pessoas que por
exemplo tinha vontade de bater nelas aí
sua qualifica se essa é a minha vontade
era essa foi atrás eu queria chamar ele
para para para a gente resolver o que
não tem para resolver nós dois que foi
para trás ele deu ó pylon então se você
brigar com ele dentro com cruzar de um
curtinho chegar perto e dentro sempre
até porque alguns braço dele vai mais
longe que o meu então é melhor para mim
eu tá embaixo e é muito dentro e jogar
bola por cima do jogo do mata cobra
direto de encontro a minha estratégia
tava tá batendo com a tua é isso mesmo é
isso mesmo vai dar certo depois da nossa
a gente vai mostrar essa estratégia e
depois da nossa você vai me ajudar e
outra coisa também eu acho que a gente
deveria aproveitar também esse momento
depois nosso começar a fazer uns eventos
de box aqui para ela lá alguns talentos
também e a gente tentar também nessa
nessa nessa nosso
a fazer alguns evento de boxe chamar
essa galera para o neto para o fight aí
pegar os melhores lutadores do Brasil né
eu tenho eu sou Embaixador aqui eu sou
eu sou diretor do boxe brasileiro da
associação Mundial de Boxe então e tem
toda abertura de fazer alguns titular
Tinho até mundial a gente vai trazer
para cá um massa então
e vai dar certo olhar triste vem cá
velho pergunta que não quer calar vai
muita gente em casa quer saber também
diz que saco sobrenome não é não é fácil
além de ser muito homem tem que ter
coragem tudo porque é soco o meu esporte
não é brincadeira nos posso nem brincar
resposta porrada na cara Socorro né E aí
eu quero saber essa rotina de
treinamento o que é que você tá fazendo
fazendo direitinho para ó eu eu faço eu
boto muito vídeo de motivação dos
boxeadores né que ainda esse vídeo de
motivação do Boxeador eu vejo um
pouquinho do do empenho do cara né
porque eu faço o meu treino mas a gente
tem uma tem uma feição que você faz no
treino que a feição de que se você quer
rasgar mesmo você quer ganhar tudo
rasgar Tudo Ou você quer treinar sem
você quer ficar de boa você quer ter um
físico legal você quer ter uma uma
mudança de hábitos na sua vida e tudo
mais e aí eu assisto monte de vídeo para
eu poder olhar para os cara e falar Tipo
assim não os caras
vou pegar algum lugar os cara quer ser
um negócio a mais o que ela não quer
fazer um treino igual de todo mundo os
cara quer dar o melhor de si aí eu de
manhã tomar um cafezinho faço uma
corridinha na minha corridinha tem
sempre meia hora que eu nem 5 minutos
melhor que vocês eu faço 15 vontade de
uma hora você não é você não é Mara
também exatamente aí eu vou começar
secar nessa começa assim e aí depois
disso eu chego em casa eu tomo café da
manhã zinha de de ovinho proteínas as
paradinha estudo mais à tarde eu faço
treino de manopla e peso não todos os
dias mandar o peso é uma mulher todos os
dias sempre tem manopla e o peso que é
que eu digo assim no caso levantar um
peso um fazer um agachamento fortalecer
a perna um entendeu e tudo mais assim e
nesse a corridinha eu já jogo o Card aí
também Essa eu não corro Pula Corda ele
faz uma soma para ver se você tava
tomando a vitamina D e vitamina Zinha
Claro e tal né chega depois depois eu
tenho que tomar um banhozinho cheio
é bem para repor a gente tá gravando um
documentário né que tá mostrando um
pouquinho dessa rotina de treino e até
como que a gente decide como que vai ser
o treino não só chegando e já tá fazendo
isso tá vendo aqui Lana é tem aquele
mais de 7 mesmo acho que eu tô com o
treinador eo treinador era para mim
falar assim mas é porque eu só perna tá
no treino ela tá ela tá você tá sentindo
que seu suas pernas estão ocupando seus
braços Então a gente tem que fazer 13
específico de perna e aí mostra pra
galera Como que eu tenho de pele e por
que que a gente foi até ele porque tem
gente que movimenta É porque tem gente
que pensa que o físico não tá ligado com
testa ficar ligadinho direitinho com a
cabeça direitinho entendeu e faz parte
de você ter uma consciência você olhar
para si própria e avaliar e pelas
funcionar os meus braços tão rápido Mas
minhas pernas estão acompanhando meus
braços porque Professor a pessoa vai
falar não você precisa de um treinos
específicos né de movimentação de pernas
futebol que que a galera chão do box
chama né só para você ter deve ser a
gente se forma de programação
internamento quando eu começava a
treinar para disputar um título mundial
para
o meu treinador tinha uma tabelinha
quantos rounds de manopla tem que fazer
por semana quanto saldos de espaço eu
tinha que fazer por semana quantos
rounds eu fiz desde quando eu comecei a
treinar até a luta quantos áudio de saco
eu tinha que fazer até a luta Quantos é
quantas gramas eu tinha que perder por
dia para chegar até a luta com peso
ideal Então tinha toda uma programação
de tudo isso não chegar tão louca tudo
isso tem que ser tudo na vida tem
planejamento Tudo Para tudo tem tempo
momento treino já é bom hoje eu já tenho
já tô com mais Centenário todo dia mesmo
é mais ou menos um mês atrás justamente
para luta para pegar o preparo físico
legal eu nem ficará já tem vai ficar
esperando o pai daqui tanto no dia não é
essa lanterna três vezes por semana mas
quando o agente tá aqui mais ou menos
dois meses da nossa nossa apresentação
eu tô trazendo todos os dias saco não
todos os dias
e é sombra eu faço todos os dias eu
tenho que fazer o sombra aqui é só você
ajuda a soltar o braço se achar o seu
uma pessoa está no solador eu faço todos
os dias Oito rápido de sombra mas eu
aquecimento É 8haus somar todos os dias
gosto de terminar ela ainda são muito
ainda sou muito menina ainda quero pular
umas etapas vezes porque a gente quer
bater é o bichinho da força obtida a a
sombra bicheira rolando a sombra faz que
você se olha no espelho você Concert
muitas coisas como esquiva Pedro os seus
golpes você tem um certinho um ombro
colado no queijo você olha no espelho
você ver os seus Ganchos você olha sua
movimentação de pernas se tá certinho a
perna com outra você não tá cruzando se
não tá muito aberta Então você faz uma
observação na sua própria sombra do que
você vai fazer na luta e sua tão natural
falar fazer sombra né fazer sombra é
aquele movimento é copinho vem golpe no
vento é em que você telegrafa né É como
se você tivesse
e não é isso se chama sombras obras
outro sobre ali você também tem uma
sombra um de frente com outro né que é
você e com 2 metros de distância por Bob
não pega no braço de você faz sombra
também simulando os golpes mas eu gosto
de fazer muito sombra solto eu postei
até outro dia fazer um sombra com meu
sobrinho né Bem bem dinâmico mesmo bem
técnico ou concertando ele me cercando a
gente bem perto do outro a gente tem a
noção de distância então sombra solto é
aquela sombra que você fica soltando
todos os ovos jeb direto gancho direto
cruzado direto todas Você conhece como
aumento de perna com o movimento de
Esquiva lateral um pêndulo né O que é
esquiva lateral quando você gostar de
golpe reto o pêndulo é quando você sai
de golpe cruzado e o daqui é por baixo é
o entendeu então vocês quer saber um
pouquinho que a sombra não é no momento
gostoso e aquece bastante a todos
lutadores do mundo começa a se aquecendo
fazendo suco
a todos fazer um alongamento Zinho e faz
sombra todos lutadores no São todos os
grandes lutadores do mundo aquecimento
dele é na sombra de toda vez que faz o
que sombra sombrinha sombra só voado
suado como que já fez aqui a
probabilidade de sorte seguinte você
botar 4 X 8 quanto é que dá ou três 18
da 88 16:32 então você passa 32 minutos
aquecendo fase movimentando toda
movimentando tudo movimento tempo para
aquecer o corpo para você fazer o que
hoje as tomadas que é o que o impacto VM
pacto do da manopla que impacta da luva
que impacta o saco então se aquece seu
corpo para fazer algo mais forte para o
seu corpo realmente o rapaz tem ciência
ele não é tetracampeão mundial na
conversinha não na ideia não viu era
para ter a mais títulos é porque agradar
roubou uma linda é porque eu não somente
são o box ele é tão detalhista em tantos
detalhes aumento de pele de bico do pé e
os
se você ficar com fé muito assim você
não consegue sair muito para o lado
fácil isso que eu tô apanhando atenção a
quando tu me dá uma dica entendeu Tipo
porque eu me liguei até quando eu fiz
musculação tempo eu não fazia nem isso
forte de luta ainda nenhum tipo de
esporte mas eu coloco sempre trabalhar
muito não com pé assim tem que trabalhar
muito com o pé aqui porque a facilidade
você se é pro lado é melhor se você
tiver com o pé aqui para você sair é
mais difícil se você tiver com o pé aqui
para você sair mais fácil é o é o
motorista de é o piloto de Fórmula 1 que
na curva na curva ele perde igreja nem
segunda está um pouco atrasada tá
certinho aí com 60 curva o cara já somou
dois minutos de erro ali que aí ficou
errando com o pezinho ali detalhe do pé
detalhe da rotação a sua força tá na
rotação entendeu se você quiser fazer
uma luta comigo e bota muita força e vou
descobrir se vai se cansar muito rápido
e aí eu vou me enrolar também porque a
sua ficou sai ser medida pela minhas eu
não acho que eu posto não tô preocupado
porque eu sei
é o que eu tô preocupada com seu prepara
o Facebook Quando você bota muita força
para dar o golpe é mais gás você perde
muito maquiagem entendeu então pode ser
só tudo se eu fizer que foi de uma forma
super natural para você entrar mas é um
show top aí eu percebi esse negócio
aquela bagunça daquele momento que eu
vejo você fazer muitos paga às vezes aí
vejo vc quer botar você aqui na verdade
não é querer matar o cara eu quero você
querendo mostrar o seu serviço
contundência não sei que era mostrar o
seu servido encaixe e que o cara sinta é
isso você pode bater nele forte mas com
mais rapidez novo entendeu tire tire
tire você sabe que você está que a gente
sabe que você tem que tirar a
concentração da bolsa e deixa de achar
que quando o meu braço Vai e fica é que
ele é forte razão natural é isso
entendeu É como se fosse aquele seu
Miyagi na cobra Naja em
e eu entendo não vai poder fazer essa
viagem não vai te ajudar cara obrigado
por você ter vindo aqui conversando
comigo parceiro entendeu então junto a
gente vai dar um show pra galera a
galera que fique esperando né a galera
que fica esperando também o documentário
que vai sair que vai mostrar um pouco
meio um pouco dele também também tá
gravando o dele também então logo você
vai ver um conteúdo dele né um bastidor
dessa preparação e tudo mais o do lado
dele que tem a versão dele tem a versão
minha né A minha versão mais não é que
tô chegando agora a sua essa versão que
você já sabe muito bem que ele vai fazer
aí você só tem que fazer o dever de casa
né que é a entrar na entrar no chip né
que você quer mostrar pra galera também
assim como eu aqui que a gente se a
gente se dedicar combinar um retrato a
gente chegar a gente vai fazer uma pesar
de fazer assim ó bem bonitinho agora vai
olhar e vai falar assim vai no brincar
não loucura vai ser doideira né
que você tenha gostado esse papo que
você tem impedido um pouco e o porquê
desta luta em porque a galera para a
gente na rua e fala assim como é que vai
ser isso aí moço e o que é que vai sair
ser moço Tu é doido é Eu Faço mas você
não viu percebeu ainda que eu sou doido
não eu sou doida muito tempo mano sou
doido à noite eu sou doido pra galera
gostado que a gente faz sou doido pra
galera gostado que eu faço eu e pra
galera gostar do nosso evento doido pra
galera gostar de boxe e querer fazer com
que volte sei lá para te ver eu sei lá
qualquer que é importante hoje você
voltar para TV ou não né que ninguém
sabe se é para isso que é tão importante
né é por isso que o nome do seu programa
é mais um pouco é mais um pode clique em
gostei como é de que bairro é que você
tirou Não esqueça de ir nas redes
sociais de Acelino Popó Cid ele e
acompanhar os treinos lá porque a gente
vai fazer o nosso evento e até a luta
vai ser legal você se manter informado
por mim e por ele também tamo junto é
nós e até o próximo episódio do mais não
pode não é
e eu vou passar para galera tudo mais a
galera que é mais velha do do box da
comissão e do uma que eles agir tudo
isso romântica gosta ela trouxe até você
vai divulgar tanto numa modalidade que
porque massa leite que massa e olha ai
galera todo mundo entendendo não tô
entendendo que depois que mais que faz
festa com luvas maiores com dois anos
com 14 onças e com saúde todos Hilux e
não teve resultado todo mundo entendeu e
eu fico pensando porque que o povo
Porque o povo americano Pode parecer é
tão legal ele aí quando a gente fazer as
coisas tipo exemplo se ninguém tivesse
aí primeiro ou não era teria tá até
tomando a gente banana mas mais mas a
galera tá pedindo a senha de 100 pessoas
Acho que não 99 Tá torcendo para que dê
tudo certo para que funcione sabe você
sabe quem começou algo no começo que não
entendeu o pessoal da MMA aí não
querendo desafiar um desafio
e depois que eles começaram a entender o
que é isso aqui agora e se assim for
como é que eu nunca fui [ __ ] nenhuma e
vou que ele não tá me vendo deixa
desafiar um cara desse comida que o cara
vai ter faz em qual o mínimo que você
vai ter lutando com Gabriel comida que
eu voltei lutando com um bico Pig é
muito Malévola poder fazer na verdade
não tem pô então a gente já faz um
negócio que o povo vai dar uma vida boa
para [ __ ] vai verdade vai vai te
ajudar isso faz o negócio mesmo assim
megalomaníaco e na questão de alcance né
porque para nós nem vai ser sobrar nós a
gente vai ser de carro eu vou poder
ligar para mim você não se deve ficar
para você hein aí chegar lá na hora a
gente faz um negócio aqui depois que a
gente terminar que descer do rim que
tirar a luva que cortar as gases tem que
sentar e olhar sem falar assim rapaz
você não falou que o pessoal Pelo preço
é uma chata Júnior eu não bebo não mas
vou tomar café e o mentor da assim gente
Rapaz tu viu que a galera gostou mesmo
velho cala a boca torta quem não é aqui
ó
é aquela afundada te pego as luvas boa
ver quem isso é isso que é você que seja
quer que seja patrocinador das meninas
tudo eu quero que o patrocinador Civic
quem mais valorizar o tanque Vale
entendeu mas eu vou passar a gente vai
ser só para botar você tivesse uma forma
mais ou menos quanto só para ter uma
ideia mas um outro sabe o valor né